[Music]
there are two kinds of people the ones
who currently are or have been in a
complicated relationship and the ones
who don't admit it during your time in
this trouble love affair you feel
anxious troubled you frustrated you're
not yourself because on one hand you can
live without your soulmate you remember
all the good times all the fun things
you did together but on the other hand
you know you're not okay there is
something unhealthy in this relationship
that is making you feel uneasy troubled
and at the end of the day doubtful and
you ask yourself what can I do to make
this relationship work or have I reach
an end today I'm gonna talk to you about
a love story all about my troubled love
affair with plastic seriously it's no
joke
plastic and I have a very peculiar
relationship thankfully Facebook has a
term from what I'm going to it's
complicated but why is it complicated
well on the positive side there are many
reasons why I fell in love with plastic
first I have been working for more than
10 years in the plastic and
petrochemicals industry I owe two
plastic my career growth and my
professional development actually thanks
to plastic I'm here at Stanford
something worked second you may not know
plastic like I do but plastic offers
many wonderful qualities for example in
the medical realm it has helped us to
preserve medicine longer to develop pill
capsules ask your grandmother even to
unblock blood vessels in the automotive
sector plastic wastes 50 percent less
than its substitutes and has enabled
interesting improvements in fuel
efficiency also plastic offers
interesting advantages in construction
transportation packaging even
agriculture and all of this has
translated in jobs creation economic
growth and improvements to our
day-to-day lives actually plastic is so
wonderful that we use a ton of it but
not one ton about 300 million tons of
plastic each year this is the equivalent
in weight of 900 Empire State buildings
this is more than half of the buildings
in downtown Manhattan yeah it's a lot of
plastic and this takes me to a negative
side not you guys
unfortunately plastic is not a cheap
date it is kind of high maintenance
because we waste more than half of the
plastic we demand this means we're
sending the equivalent of more than 400
Empire State buildings to our landfills
and to our oceans and we're creating a
huge damage to our ecosystem wildlife
and environment second as a rule of
thumb plastic takes around 400 years to
fully degrade this means if I waste
plastic right now is gonna stay here for
my great-great-great great-great-great
great-great great-great grandchildren to
inherit is this the legacy I want to
leave behind definitely not
and finally as you may know plastic is
the right from oil all is not cheap all
is not infinite we cannot keep feelings
Plastics all habit forever
but since I am a passionate person as
probably you have seen I needed to find
a way to make this relationship work and
sometimes the solution is staring you in
the face
but you just don't see it well that's
what happened to me and I came to
realize the importance of recycling yeah
I think it's a little bit obvious right
unfortunately recycling is hard to do
all the time and my main problem has
been commitment has this ever happened
to in a relationship let me spread it in
another way it's New Year's Day you tend
to realize that pretty much since
Thanksgiving I ate a lot partied a lot
maybe drank a lot so as a New Year's
resolution I decide to go to the gym and
if I were to see this graphically it
would look something like this
the first day I will rush to the gym at
6:00 in the morning it's really crowded
by the way and I will workout 1 hour and
a half and probably do it 3 to 4 times
that week and I'll keep do it the next
week and the next week will happy
sustain passes on about how our
priorities so instead of going four to
five times a week although maybe two or
three instead of going maybe one hour
and a half I do one hour maybe 45
minutes because there are other
important things to do so my priority my
commitment will go down something like
this unfortunately the same thing
happens with recycling and I need to ask
myself what can I do to maintain a
strong commitment all the time I need to
find a way to make this habit stick and
that's what I understood that I need to
differentiate myself and I had to go and
advocate for recycle what I'm gonna
advocate in three ways number one a lot
of it to myself that every time I waste
something I'll think 400 years and
that's gonna become a mantra 400 years
because that's the legacy I'm leaving
behind number two I'll advocate to my
peers family friends of their legacy if
they don't recycle also find a recycling
bin even if you have to just walk a few
extra steps
if there is no recycling bin provide one
just by walking these few extra steps or
by stretching your arm to this
additional container you can do a huge
difference but you may ask yourself why
is this gonna maintain a strong
commitment all the time I don't need to
do something more
I needed to compel myself push myself
beyond my comfort zone and this is how I
decided
very much to advocate to an audience
each and every one of you are witnesses
of my commitment witnesses to remind
myself of my mantra for hundred years
every one of you including the people at
the other side of the camera and on
social media
it is a strong commitment but it is
something that I need to do in order to
make my relationship with plastic work
I'm totally important because after the
GSB after Stanford I'm going to go back
to the plastic and petrochemicals
industry and I'm gonna push for
sustainable initiatives because I want
to make my relationship with plastic
work because I use plastic every day and
I love plastic with this let me ask you
just one question who use plastic today
who is using it right now could you
raise your plastic bottles
look around look at yourselves
it seems you also have a complicated
relationship with plastic but what are
you doing about it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]